i've been eating insects for years
but what i see as a tasty snack
could be seen as disgusting by someone
else but what's the psychological reason
for that let's dig in
disgust is actually a defense mechanism
that evolved to keep us safe from all
kinds of diseases josh ackerman a social
psychologist at the university of
michigan told me that we have a whole
host of ways of psychological ways of
dealing with with those infections all
the emotions and thoughts and
ways of managing our environment those
safety strategies make up our behavioral
immune system think of it as a set of
behaviors that work to prevent infection
for instance the more likely people were
to feel disgust from certain foods the
more they tended to stick with certain
covet prevention strategies like social
distancing and hand washing according to
this 2021 study
a similar study found that during the
pandemic people became more sensitive to
discuss provoking stimuli like someone
sneezing next to you in the elevator
or even vanilla ice cream with ketchup
on it
that suggests an increased awareness of
potential dangers
so back to those insects i was snacking
on earlier despite their high protein
content edible insects usually get a bad
rep for being dirty and that can be
scary because filth can lead to disease
so if you have a motivation to avoid
disease avoid contamination like with
foods it's really to experience this
kind of withdrawal like getting back
moving away
maybe even like spitting something out
uh getting away from that food another
indicator that sets off our behavioral
immune system is that something looks
just like this beastly brown avocado
looks like it should be thrown out
sounds superficial but our behavioral
immune system relies a lot on our sense
of sight and when foods don't look like
we expect them to then we tend to be a
little bit more cautious about eating
those things and especially if we see
things like
um
like discoloration on food scent is
another powerful cue the behavioral
immune system uses to protect us did you
notice how i curled my lips and moved
away when i saw the discolored flesh
that might prevent
unpleasant smells from entering the nose
foods that are rotting usually smell bad
like milk or meat pass their prime and
that alerts our brains that we shouldn't
consume them our taste and smell systems
connect up to the limbic area of the
brain which is involved in processing
our responses to threats
one key region is the hypothalamus which
controls our fight or flight response
the limbic system is also important for
controlling the emotional responses that
help us determine whether we like
certain foods or are grossed out by them
this gut feeling is critical especially
when we haven't encountered something
before like me with this durian it's a
spike covered tropical fruit whose
strong smell seems some people running
yes
it looks like a dinosaur egg
okay i don't think that's for me it
tastes like something that's fermented
and gone bad
just like people might not like insects
i didn't like this
we often forget this but the brain is a
prediction machine that means it's
constantly scanning the environment with
all of our senses to predict potential
outcomes
but if the brain doesn't have prior good
outcomes to refer back to it tends to
default to safety so people are much
more averse to foods that come from
other cultures if they haven't
experienced those in the past even if
those foods don't show any signs of
contamination when something deviates
from normal or is unfamiliar the brain
alerts us that something might not be
quite right think of when you walked on
a transparent platform and looked down
or the first time you walked into a
crowded train after covet lockdowns that
apprehension you felt that's your brain
trying to keep you alive and well it's a
similar phenomenon with food it also
could be that those foods have
um bacteria that you haven't been
exposed to and that you can't handle
very well and so
those foods may in fact be more likely
to make you sick but like your brain
your gut is adaptive your digestive and
nervous systems learn to cope with new
challenges and that's a good thing
because a lot of foods we might
instinctively avoid can be good for us
so what might help us get over our
initial aversions josh told me that
presentation makes a big difference the
queue of the sealed package itself
indicates to people that this is
probably safe and because food is social
friends
josh told me that this need to connect
can sometimes override or disgust i knew
durian would stink and maybe set up my
disgust but i have a friend who raves
about it so i went into it with an open
mind but i didn't end up liking it it
actually activated my gag reflex
it's your body's way of trying to get
rid of something it perceives as bad so
next time you're confronted with a
choice of trying a new and maybe unusual
food or activity use your frame to
figure out whether it's really unsafe or
whether you're just scared to try
something different
[Music]
you